ÐÏ à¡± á > þÿ D P þÿÿÿ E ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿþÿ
à…ŸòùOh «‘ +'³Ù0 ¸ ˜ è ô 4
H T
t €
Œ ˜ ¨ ° ä H >> CUTTS: We have a good
question from Majico in London, United Kingdom
paramedix Normal.dot paramedix 39 Microsoft
Office Word @ ´ @ DQ§Ò`Ê @ b äaÊ Ê
m a l . d o t
Anþÿ ÕÍÕœ. “— +,ù®D ÕÍÕœ.
“— +,ù®˜ T
p x ˜  ¨ ° ¸ À È Ð Ø
à 4 ä Arriba Telecontact Inc. À Y Â æ
H >> CUTTS: We have a good question from Majico
in London, United Kingdom Title H Õ Ý å
í õ ý RTCharacterCount RTCharLineCount
65LineCount LineCountAdjustment RTLineCount
RTPageCount ä g E E E ¨ ° ä H >> CUTTS:
We have a good question from Majico in London,
United Kingdom paramedix Normal.dot paramedix
39 Microsoft Office Word @ ´ @ DQ§Ò`Ê
@ b äaÊ Ê m a l . d o t
An >> SEAN: Hi, Raymond, thank you for coming
to the Google I/O. Great pleasure to have
you guys. Thanks for coming to the Sandbox,
and the (inaudible).
>> RAMON: Yeah, I know, Sean, actually, it’s
a pleasure for me to be here, you know, OpenSocial—it’s
great to see the whole community out here
of the OpenSocial, about the Containers, and
App developers, and people are just interested
and kind of getting into the ecosystem. So,
being able to be here and participate plus
down loading some of our stuff and being able
to take some Q&A, its’ all really exciting,
actually.
>> SEAN: Great, thank you. So, we have the
new spec of the 0.9 coming up…
>> RAMON: Right.
>> SEAN: Are there any features, specific
that are exciting to you and do you like to
share with us?
>> RAMON: Definitely, I mean, you know, 0.9
spec recently got—I guess approved, you
know, a couple of months ago and two things,
performance is really important for us, right?
I mean, all our products are trying to get
that user-experience improved, trying to get
it to be snappy, responsive, and I think that
Proxied Content and Data Pipelining are going
to be huge. So, Proxied Content, of course,
making it to reduce number of round trips,
we have to do by allowing that initial page
load to be proxied through the App developer
side. That will be really great in terms of
reducing those initial load times. Another
thing of course is Data Pipelining which will
allow the container to preload data and render
it either directly to our servers in terms
of—for Proxied Content, we’re actually
rendering it in line with the eye frame for
gadgets that’s still want to stick with
that traditional JavaScript model. Both of
those, eliminating those extra round trips,
back and forth that we have to do now, in
terms of doing an extra make request or an
extra JSON few request. Those are going to
be great for performance and so I'm really
looking forward for, you know all the major
containers to start implementing some of those
features.
>> SEAN: Great, great.
>> RAMON: Yeah.
>> SEAN: So, in the space, what we see is
that, you know, the virtual economy based
on model, and those gaming apps, they tend
to make profitable money than the ones…
>> RAMON: Yeah. Sure.
>> SEAN: So, to that end we’ve intermitted
this Virtual Currency API in the new spec…
>> RAMON: Right.
>> SEAN: I see, you guys already have, you
know, both wanted the App RockYou pets on
Hi-5 with, you know, virtual coins are already
in place.
>> RAMON: Yeah.
>> SEAN: How did that benefit your App?
>> RAMON: Right, well, I mean, just to start
off, you know, at the top, definitely, what
we’ve seen is we’ve seen a lot of new
business models become viable and you know,
advertising is still a great place to be,
but with Virtual Currency, it’s really growing
new source of revenue for a lot of companies.
For us, you now, Hi-5 coins—it’s been
a great opportunity. One of the things that
we see, we’re doing Virtual Currency on
containers that don’t have a container currency
is that, there is a large drop-off, right?
I mean, users get into the App, they get to
the point where they need to put in some form
of money into the system and they see, like,
an application developers specific kind of
interface and they may not trust it, they
may not understand what it’s about…
>> SEAN: Right.
>> RAMON: There’s a lot of drop-off there,
plus the opportunity of having container currency
is that, we really reduce that drop-off. And
you know, and as you can see, it’s been
pretty successful on Hi-5.
>> SEAN: How was the developing process, was
it pretty easy to integrate, like in, the
API is the easy to (inaudible) to the existing
Apps?
>> RAMON: Right, I mean, you know, so, I believe
it’s still kind of a working standard, a
working draft for the currency API, but, yeah,
it’s a very straightforward process for
an application on Hi-5 to implement their
currency. It’s basically, there's a client
inside JavaScript call, so you prompt the
user to, you know, put in container currency
and then what happens is that the container
then has server side callbacks back to the
App developer server in order to register
the fact of that currency has been, you know,
deducted or passed on.
>> SEAN: Right.
>> RAMON: So, very, very simple integration
actually. And the hope for us is that since
it will be a standard that other containers
are going to implement it and, you know, it’ll
just be like OpenSocial itself. The great
benefit is that, once we get it working in
one place, its’ going to be really as trivial
to port other places.
>> SEAN: How long did it take you guys to
implement the Virtual Currency with the Hi-5?
>> RAMON: Well, you know, I think, actually,
the initial implementation was really fast,
maybe on the order of, like, a day or two.
>> SEAN: Okay.
>> RAMON: You know, then, they're doing some
testing, I mean, at the time Hi-5 was still,
I think, launching the system, so there's
some (inaudible) but, you know, once it’s
up and running, I think most developers can
get up there in no time at all, like, really
straightforward.
>> SEAN: It sounds like all the developers
should take advantage of this new feature
and then…
>> RAMON: Yeah, you know, I think that App
developers who are doing stuff with virtual
goods in Virtual Currency, this is a big thing.
I think this will be really exciting for me.
>> SEAN: Great, great. Well, thank you very
much for coming to talk with us and nice working
on your great App.
>> RAMON: Yeah, all right. Thanks a lot Sean.
>> SEAN: Thank you.
: < ] u Š ‹ • – — ˜ › ® Ç
ã ä ë ì 8 : C D e ƒ ¢ © ­ Ö Ú ç
?
’
ž
»
* N ` å æ þ , 8 ; > ? @ K L P Q u w } ~ … ¬ Ê
‚
ˆ
þ
ÿ
„ ùõñíñíñõéõíõñåáõÝõñíõíñõñõñÙñÙõÙõÙõñÙõÕñÕÑÕñÕÑÕÑÕñÕÑÕñÕñÕñÕñÕñÕñÍÕñÍÕÍÕñÕñÕñÕñÕñÕ
hä!“ hÜ@¡ h8 q hÈVl hÃy hþvï hä)Ï
h}V
h o h5O, hÖ(Ü héP hQJ€ Q ˜ ?
Š
›
Û ò © À ' µ Å í ÷ Õ a … • ã
; ¿ Î æ E û l ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú
ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú
ú ú ú ú ú ú ú gdÖ(Ü ¯ ý „ ¥ T
X “ Ú Û ð õ ú T U X ^ i ‡ § ¬ ± É
Ê ð ñ ø ù I i l w { € « ´ µ ¸ ½
è ì ð õ Ë Ì Ó Ô è
5 6 ; ‡ ˆ
Ñ Ó æ ÿ ? I J ` a d i $ ( â ÿ ˜ üøôüôðôøüôìôüôüèôèôèôìôäôäôäôìôèôäèäôàôàìàäàìàäàäàèàèäàäàäàäàìàÜàØàØÔÐÌàÌìÌäÌØÌì
h Z& hþvï hä)Ï hxrî h }£ hXU_ h}V
h,\¤ h5O, h}n] h¯b· h8 q hä!“ P ö ù
: ; > C \ ] d h Ñ Ö W a b r w þ ? C H
M Ë ú û 7 ` g j ¯ l* Š* à* ê* ò* ö*
þ* + + + 6+ >+ ”+ ˜+ + Ò+ ú+ T, . üøüøüøôøðøðøôøìèøäøäøäøôøôøôäôäôðôàÜØÔÐÔÐÔÌÐÌÐÈÄÐÄÀ¼¸
hî § hä håW h
bY h[aÊ h‹ Š h–I¥ hÀv7 hâ \ h G¬
hõe¡ h}n] hþvï hä)Ï h}V
h5O, h }£ h Z& 5N : . . . i s w i l l b e
r e a l l y e x c i t i n g f o r u s , . † œ
@ @ñÿ @ N o r m a l CJ _H aJ mH sH tH D
A@òÿ¡ D D e f a u l t P a r a g r a p h
F o n t R i óÿ³ R T a b l e N o r m a l
ö 4Ö
l 4Ö aö ( k ôÿÁ ( N o L i s t D Z@ ò
D éP
P l a i n T e x t CJ OJ QJ ^J aJ á * ÿÿÿÿ
ÿÿ z™ ÿÿ z™ ë
á ‰ ž B ž è ÿ ¿ Ö / @ Ê Ú
ë
t ” ¤ ò c ç ö v , Í ã ‚% û1 ‚% û1
‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1
‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1
‚% û1 ž B ž è ÿ ¿ Ö / @ Ê Ú
ë
t ” ¤ ò c ç ö v , Í ã ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ˜ 0 € € ž B ž è ÿ ¿ Ö
@ Ê Ú
ë
ã š 0 € € š 0 € € ˜ 0 € € š
0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š
0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € š 0 € € š 0 € € „ . l
ê* ¯ ð8 ð @ ñ ÿÿ ÿ €€€ ÷ ð’
ð ð0 ð( ð
ð ðB
ð S ð ¿ Ë ÿ ? ð ã ã ý þ • ™ G
K å
é
7 ; [ [ » ¼ ½ ½ D H I b B D ‘ q u ( * Å
Ç ã ã i å h Ãy }V
ïy éP o W p ä • C Nm! â0# Ô`$ Z& 9'
5O, Ï$. ê 7 Àv7 OB9 ¦8: • ; * D ÔdJ
á K ª5Q ° U ƒ8X
EX u
Y
bY " \ â \ }n] XU_ ?ea `If Cff ÈVl 8 q “pq
ÉKu v åW úo QJ€ ³+„ «S… Þ ‡ âS‡
z‰ ‹ Š ·6‹ Œ "Œ
WŒ ª,Ž ‹ Ö} ä!“ z ™ ¢qž í Ÿ
Ü@¡ õe¡ }£ ¯ ¤ ,\¤ –I¥ î § š&¬
G¬ Lyµ ¯b· p º é ¼ Ð#Â º0Â —&Ã
)aÃ [aÊ (mÊ ä)Ï U*Ï /?Ð P"Ø $Ù Ö(Ü
W[á * å é
ì xrî $Xï þvï fñ qXó pkó —Bô Æ
÷ ôYø ?ú {ý ç þ kjþ ÿ@ € þ þ
°˜ ° ° þ þ Ì ? A B C E F Œ œ - 2
ã ½ ¾ ¿ È ­ ± # $ 8 4 9 n p v x ¯ ° ý
þ ~ – ª õ ü * . / • ™ ¸ ¢
¤
G K • ¯ ° Ì Í
g
h
å
é
V ^ 7 ; { € ‘ ” ¹ º î ï V [ » ¼
½ D H I M V _ b B D ‘ q u * Å Ç à á
Q @ Q 4* Q 8* Q :* Q <* Q @* Q Š @ Q B* P
, @ Q b* Q \ @ P À @ Q l* Q t @ Q n* Q ‚ @ Q
€* Q L @ Q ˆ* Q 2 @ Q \ @ Q Š* Q \ @ Q
”* Q È @ Q ˜* Q Ö @ Q œ* P F @ Q . P
â @ Q ž* Q ä @ Q * P (! @ Q È* Q Ö*
Q Ö! @ Q à* P è* P ," @ Q ê* Q # @ P F#
@ Q ò* Q % @ Q ö* Q j& @ Q þ* Q ' @ Q
+ Q 8' @ Q + Q r' @ Q + P ì) @ Q + Q ¤* @ Q
+ P ¦+ @ Q + Q è+ @ Q &+ P –, @ Q 6+ Q
P. @ Q >+ Q Þ. @ Q H+ Q / @ Q N+ Q Z/ @ Q
P+ Q R+ Q ü/ @ Q Š+ P ˜0 @ Q ”+ Q 2 @ Q
–+ Q X3 @ P \3 @ Q ˜+ Q r4 @ Q + Q ¨+
Q º+ Q Ì+ P t4 @ Q Ò+ Q 86 @ Q Ö+ P Æ6
@ Q ú+ Q Þ7 @ Q , P ˆ8 @ Q , P ò9 @ Q
P, P *; @ P \; @ ÿÿ U n k n o w n ÿÿ ÿÿ
ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ G ‡z € ÿ T i m e
s N e w R o m a n 5 € S y m b o l 3& ‡z
€ † œ @ @ñÿ @ N o r m a l CJ _H aJ
mH sH tH D A òÿ¡ D D e f a u l t P a r
a g r a p h F o n t R i óÿ³ R T a b l e
N o r m a l ö 4Ö
l 4Ö aö ( k ôÿÁ ( N o L i s t D Z@ ò
D éP
P l a i n T e x t CJ OJ QJ ^J aJ á * ÿÿÿÿ
ÿÿ z™ ÿÿ z™ ë
á ‰ ž B ž è ÿ ¿ Ö / @ Ê Ú
ë
t ” ¤ ò c ç ö v , Í ã ‚% û1 ‚% û1
‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1
‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1
‚% û1 ž B ž è ÿ ¿ Ö / @ Ê Ú
ë
t ” ¤ ò c ç ö v , Í ã ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ˜ 0 € € ž B ž è ÿ ¿ Ö
@ Ê Ú
ë
ã š 0 € € š 0 € € ˜ 0 € € š
0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š
0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € š 0 € € š 0 € € „ . l
ê* ¯ ð8 ð @ ñ ÿÿ ÿ €€€ ÷ ð’
ð ð0 ð( ð
ð ðB
ð S ð ¿ Ë ÿ ? ð ø ý ã ° A è ÿ
N O ã : : ý þ • ™ G K å
é
7 ; [ [ » ¼ ½ ½ D H I b B D ‘ q u ( * Å
Ç ã ø ý ã h å g Ãy }V
ïy éP o W p ä • C Nm! â0# Ô`$ Z& 9'
5O, Ï$. ê 7 Àv7 OB9 ¦8: • ; * D ÔdJ
á K ª5Q ° U ƒ8X
EX u
Y
bY " \ â \ }n] XU_ ?ea `If Cff ÈVl 8 q “pq
ÉKu v åW úo QJ€ ³+„ «S… Þ ‡ âS‡
z‰ ‹ Š ·6‹ Œ "Œ
WŒ ª,Ž ‹ Ö} ä!“ z ™ ¢qž í Ÿ
Ü@¡ õe¡ }£ ¯ ¤ ,\¤ –I¥ î § š&¬
G¬ Lyµ ¯b· p º é ¼ Ð#Â º0Â —&Ã
)aÃ [aÊ (mÊ ä)Ï U*Ï /?Ð P"Ø $Ù Ö(Ü
W[á * å é
ì xrî $Xï þvï fñ qXó pkó —Bô Æ
÷ ?ú {ý ç þ kjþ ÿ@ € þ þ °˜ þ
þ Ì ? A B C E F Œ œ - 2 ã ½ ¾ ¿ È
­ ± # $ 8 4 9 n p v x ¯ ° ý þ ~ – ª
õ ü * . / • ™ ¸ ¢
¤
G K • ¯ ° Ì Í
g
h
å
é
V ^ 7 ; { € ‘ ” ¹ º î ï V [ » ¼
½ D H I M V _ b B D ‘ q u * Å Ç à á
Q @ Q 4* Q 8* Q :* Q <* Q @* Q Š @ Q B* P
, @ Q b* Q \ @ P À @ Q l* Q t @ Q n* Q ‚ @ Q
€* Q L @ Q ˆ* Q 2 @ Q \ @ Q Š* Q \ @ Q
”* Q È @ Q ˜* Q Ö @ Q œ* P F @ Q . P
â @ Q ž* Q ä @ Q * P (! @ Q È* Q Ö*
Q Ö! @ Q à* P è* P ," @ Q ê* Q # @ P F#
@ Q ò* Q % @ Q ö* Q j& @ Q þ* Q ' @ Q
+ Q 8' @ Q + Q r' @ Q + P ì) @ Q + Q ¤* @ Q
+ P ¦+ @ Q + Q è+ @ Q &+ P –, @ Q 6+ Q
P. @ Q >+ Q Þ. @ Q H+ Q / @ Q N+ Q Z/ @ Q
P+ Q R+ Q ü/ @ Q Š+ P ˜0 @ Q ”+ Q 2 @ Q
–+ Q X3 @ P \3 @ Q ˜+ Q r4 @ Q + Q ¨+
Q º+ Q Ì+ P t4 @ Q Ò+ Q 86 @ Q Ö+ P Æ6
@ Q ú+ Q Þ7 @ Q , P ˆ8 @ Q , P ò9 @ Q
P, P *; @ P \; @ ÿÿ U n k n o w n ÿÿ ÿÿ
ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ G ‡z € ÿ T i m e
s N e w R o m a n 5 € S y m b o l 3& ‡z
€ ÿ A r i a l ?5 ‡z € ÿ C o u r i
e r N e w " ñ ˆ ðÐ h JÛ&;TÛF 0 ÿ â
& [ ÿ â & [ ! ð ' ´ ´ >4 d » » 3ƒ
ð HP (ðÿ ? ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ
ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ "Œ 2 ÿÿ G > > C U
T T S : W e h a v e a g o o d q u e s t i
o n f r o m M a j i c o i n L o n d o n , U
n i t e d K i n g d o m p a r a m e d i x
p a r a m e d i x † œ @ @ñÿ @ N o r m
a l CJ _H aJ mH sH tH D A@òÿ¡ D D e f a
u l t P a r a g r a p h F o n t R i óÿ³
R T a b l e N o r m a l ö 4Ö
l 4Ö aö ( k ôÿÁ ( N o L i s t D Z@ ò
D éP
P l a i n T e x t CJ OJ QJ ^J aJ á * ÿÿÿÿ
ÿÿ z™ ÿÿ z™ ë
á ‰ ž B ž è ÿ ¿ Ö / @ Ê Ú
ë
t ” ¤ ò c ç ö v , Í ã ‚% û1 ‚% û1
‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1
‚% û1 ‚% û1 ‚% û1
‚% û1 ž B ž è ÿ ¿ Ö / @ Ê Ú
ë
t ” ¤ ò c ç ö v , Í ã ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ˜ 0 € € ž B ž è ÿ ¿ Ö
@ Ê Ú
ë
ã š 0 € € š 0 € € ˜ 0 € € š
0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š
0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € š 0 € € š 0 € € „ . l
ê* ¯ ð8 ð @ ñ ÿÿ ÿ €€€ ÷ ð’
ð ð0 ð( ð
ð ðB
ð S ð ¿ Ë ÿ ? ð ã ã ý þ • ™ G
K å
é
7 ; [ [ » ¼ ½ ½ D H I b B D ‘ q u ( * Å
Ç ã ã i å h Ãy }V
ïy éP o W p ä • C Nm! â0# Ô`$ Z& 9'
5O, Ï$. ê 7 Àv7 OB9 ¦8: • ; * D ÔdJ
á K ª5Q ° U ƒ8X
EX u
Y
bY " \ â \ }n] XU_ ?ea `If Cff ÈVl 8 q “pq
ÉKu v åW úo QJ€ ³+„ «S… Þ ‡ âS‡
z‰ ‹ Š ·6‹ Œ "Œ
WŒ ª,Ž ‹ Ö} ä!“ z ™ ¢qž í Ÿ
Ü@¡ õe¡ }£ ¯ ¤ ,\¤ –I¥ î § š&¬
G¬ Lyµ ¯b· p º é ¼ Ð#Â º0Â —&Ã
)aÃ [aÊ (mÊ ä)Ï U*Ï /?Ð P"Ø $Ù Ö(Ü
W[á * å é
ì xrî $Xï þvï fñ qXó pkó —Bô Æ
÷ ôYø ?ú {ý ç þ kjþ ÿ@ € þ þ
°˜ ° ° þ þ Ì ? A B C E F Œ œ - 2
ã ½ ¾ ¿ È ­ ± # $ 8 4 9 n p v x ¯ ° ý
þ ~ – ª õ ü * . / • ™ ¸ ¢
¤
G K • ¯ ° Ì Í
g
h
å
é
V ^ 7 ; { € ‘ ” ¹ º î ï V [ » ¼
½ D H I M V _ b B D ‘ q u * Å Ç à á
Q @ Q 4* Q 8* ÿ A r i a l ?5 ‡z € ÿ
C o u r i e r N e w " ñ ˆ ðÐ h JÛ&;TÛF
0 ÿ â & [ ÿ â & [ ! ð ' ´ ´ ~4 d
» » 3ƒ ð HP (ðÿ ? ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ
ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ "Œ 2 ÿÿ G > > C
U T T S : W e h a v e a g o o d q u e s t
i o n f r o m M a j i c o i n L o n d o n
, U n i t e d K i n g d o m p a r a m e d
i x p a r a m e d i x 2 1 h :péP °Ð/ °à=!°'
"°' #  $  %° °Ð °Ð Ð I t s a f
a r s i d e t o c h a t w i t h o t o t h
e r t h e t p e e r , , C A q u i t e a b
i t o f m o r e i m p l e m e n t e d . . . ?
H i F i , H i F i w i t h C C . . . C H i
F i m e n t h o o k i n H i F i s i t e t
o C C o n t a i n e r t h e n h a s s e r
v e r s i t t h a t C H i F i A d a y o r
a f e w h o u r s ? F i k i n k s t o w o
r k o u t S E A ì¥Á q` ô ¿ ¯ bjbjqPqP
0 : : á ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ ¤ ê ê ê ê ê
ê > ô Z Z Z Z v 2 ^ ö – – – – – q
q
! # # # # # # $ T h ¼ Ü G Ñ ê q
G ê ê – – Û e e e q
ê – ê – ! e q
! e e ê ê e – Š pë9 äaÊ Z {
e ! . 0 ^ e ˜ …
Ö ˜ e l › ¯ ê* ú ú ú gdÖ(Ü Q :* Q
<* Q @* Q Š @ Q B* P , @ Q b* Q \ @ P À
@ Q l* Q t @ Q n* Q ‚ @ Q €* Q L @ Q
ˆ* Q 2 @ Q \ @ Q Š* Q \ @ Q ”* Q È @ Q
˜* Q Ö @ Q œ* P F @ Q . P â @ Q ž* Q
ä @ Q * P (! @ Q È* Q Ö* Q Ö! @ Q à*
P è* P ," @ Q ê* Q # @ P F# @ Q ò* Q % @ Q
ö* Q j& @ Q þ* Q ' @ Q
+ Q 8' @ Q + Q r' @ Q + P ì) @ Q + Q ¤* @ Q
+ P ¦+ @ Q + Q è+ @ Q &+ P –, @ Q 6+ Q
P. @ Q >+ Q Þ. @ Q H+ Q / @ Q N+ Q Z/ @ Q
P+ Q R+ Q ü/ @ Q Š+ P ˜0 @ Q ”+ Q 2 @ Q
–+ Q X3 @ P \3 @ Q ˜+ Q r4 @ Q + Q ¨+
Q º+ Q Ì+ P t4 @ Q Ò+ Q 86 @ Q Ö+ P Æ6
@ Q ú+ Q Þ7 @ Q , P ˆ8 @ Q , P ò9 @ Q
P, P *; @ P \; @ ÿÿ U n k n o w n ÿÿ ÿÿ
ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ G ‡z € ÿ T i m e
s N e w R o m a n 5 € S y m b o l 3& ‡z
€ ÿ A r i a l ?5 ‡z € ÿ C o u r i
e r N e w " ñ Š ðÐ h JÛ&;TÛF ' 0 Ê
Y Ê Y ! ð '  ´ ´ ~4 d Â Â 3ƒ ð HP
(ðÿ ? ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ
ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ "Œ 2 ÿÿ G > > C U T T S : W
e h a v e a g o o d q u e s t i o n f r o
m M a j i c o i n L o n d o n , U n i t e
d K i n g d o m p a r a m e d i x p a r a
m e d i x € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ì¥Á q` ô ¿ ¯ bjbjqPqP 0 : : á
ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ ¤ ê ê ê ê ê ê > ô Z
Z Z Z v 2 ^ ö – – – – – q
q
! # # # # # # $ T h ¼ Ü G Ñ ê q
G ê ê – – Û e e e q
ê – ê – ! e q
! e e ê ê e – Š póº$äaÊ Z {
e ! . 0 ^ e ˜ …
Ö ˜ e ˜ ê e ¼ q
q
e q
G G [
q
^ q
2 2 2 ä
D 2 2 2
þ $ " : ê ê ê ê ê ê ÿÿÿÿ R o o
t E n t r y ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ À F póº$äaÊ
G @ 1 T a b l e ÿÿÿÿ . ˜ W o r d D o
c u m e n t ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ A 0 S u m m a
r y I n f o r m a t i o n ( ÿÿÿÿ è ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
< þÿÿÿ 7 ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ/
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 = 8 þÿÿÿ ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ9
> ? @ þÿÿÿB C F ýÿÿÿþÿÿÿH I þÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿþÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
D o c u m e n t S u m m a r y I n f o r m
a t i o n 8 ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
¨ C o m p O b j ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
q 0 T a b l e ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ ˜ ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
þÿ
ÿÿÿÿ À F Microsoft Office Word Document
MSWordDoc Word.Document.8 ô9²q þÿ à…ŸòùOh
«‘ +'³Ù0 ¸ ˜ è ô 4 H T
t €
Œ ˜ ¨ ° ä H >> CUTTS: We have a good
question from Majico in London, United Kingdom
paramedix Normal.dot paramedix 39 Microsoft
Office Word @ ´ @ DQ§Ò`Ê @ b äaÊ Ê
þÿ ÕÍÕœ. “— +,ù®D ÕÍÕœ. “— +,ù®˜
T
p x ˜  ¨ ° ¸ À È Ð Ø
à 4 ä Arriba Telecontact Inc. À Y Â æ
H >> CUTTS: We have a good question from Majico
in London, United Kingdom Title H Õ Ý å
í õ ý RTCharacterCount RTCharLineCount
65LineCount LineCountAdjustment RTLineCount
RTPageCount ä g E E E ˜ ê e ¼ q
q
e q
G G [
q
^ q
2 2 2 ä
D 2 2 2
þ $ " : ê ê ê ê ê ê ÿÿÿÿ R o o
t E n t r y ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ À F pë9 äaÊ
N @ 1 T a b l e ÿÿÿÿ ! Ð W o r d D o
c u m e n t ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ : 0 S u m m a
r y I n f o r m a t i o n ( ÿÿÿÿ è ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
< þÿÿÿ 7 " # $ % & ' ( ) * + , - þÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ8
þÿÿÿ ; J 9 ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
M ýÿÿÿþÿÿÿO Q þÿÿÿþÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
D o c u m e n t S u m m a r y I n f o r m
a t i o n 8 ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
¨ C o m p O b j ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
q 0 T a b l e ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ ˜ ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
þÿ
ÿÿÿÿ À F Microsoft Office Word Document
MSWordDoc Word.Document.8 ô9²q þÿ à…ŸòùOh
«‘ +'³Ù0 ¸ ˜ è ô 4 H T
t €
Œ ˜ ¨ ° ä H >> CUTTS: We have a good
question from Majico in London, United Kingdom
paramedix Normal.dot paramedix 32 Microsoft
Office Word @ ´ @ DQ§Ò`Ê @ b äaÊ ÿ
â þÿ ÕÍÕœ. “— +,ù®D ÕÍÕœ.
“— +,ù®˜ T
p x ˜  ¨ ° ¸ À È Ð Ø
à 4 ä Arriba Telecontact Inc. n [ & » æ
H >> CUTTS: We have a good question from Majico
in London, United Kingdom þÿÿÿ þÿÿÿ
þÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ